there are no moms in one piece and
that's a great thing like with mothers
one piece just doesn't work as crazy as
it may sound and i can't believe i'm
saying this but crocodile might actually
be luffy's mother because i found a lot
of new evidence for the croco mom theory
but that being said i also found a
number of other very possible candidates
and i'll show you just how important
luffy meeting his mother will be for the
entire story
i really can't explain it but luffy's
mom is one of those mysteries in one
piece that even though they don't seem
to matter like at all for the story
right now i just can't help but obsess a
little bit about i mean there's
something really weird going on with
mothers in one piece in general and i
absolutely refuse to believe that we
won't get to know the mother of the
pirate king himself what's up my name is
manu and just like you assume my mom
means the world to me of course there
are exceptions to this but generally i
think moms score pretty high on the
things people tend to love no matter
what list and so today i finally have
the chance to talk about something that
has bothered me for a while now you know
how shonen characters all seem to have
pretty bad i have no doubt syndrome well
one piece takes this a whole step
further here everyone seems to suffer
from wait i don't even get a mom
syndrome as well
[Music]
and as it turns out there is actually a
reason for this that i think is
important to discuss before we get into
luffy's mom specifically okay how do i
put this
there are
no mothers in one piece ah that's a
weirder sentence to say out loud than i
originally thought it would be but it is
an undeniable fact none of the straw
hats has a mother as of right now luffy
zorro and jinbe have never mentioned
their parents frankie and chopper got
abandoned by theirs brook's parents must
be dead because he's a grandpa and robin
usop sanji and nami have all lost their
mothers under the most tragic
circumstances
[Music]
and what i just realized is that those
four share incredibly similar arcs as
well all their mothers were incredibly
kind and brave people that then
inherited that kindness to their
children
[Music]
all of them then had the most terrible
and lonely childhoods after they lost
their mothers suffering under a terrible
lack of self-confidence and all four of
them were the ones that opposed luffy
and the crew out of that sense that they
were not worth anything and in the end
under tears accepted luffy's
unconditional love for them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
now that i think about it you can
actually spin that in the other
direction as well chomper and frankie
are the most quirky members of the crew
with the
non-normals if you want not because they
are a cyborg and a reindeer but because
they were abandoned only now fitting in
with the crew that actually loves and
accepts them and lastly the four members
that don't seem to have a tragic
backstory with their moms at least yet
are the four emotionally most stable
ones
luffy zorro brook and jinbei i feel
share that aura of stability and
groundedness
[Music]
does clearly have some issues of his own
that probably relate to growing up
without parents and always fighting ever
since he was a kid i hope we'll get to
meet his parents soon actually jinbe's
darkness stems more from the
discrimination of his people as a whole
and brooks is spending such a long time
alone
[Music]
but i find it beyond interesting that
there seems to be a clear pattern
connected to mothers in the story and so
it was really no big surprise to find
out that this lack of motherly care was
not an accident but something
consciously decided by author a chiroda
as he explained in an sbs mothers for
him are the opposite of adventure they
take care of their children and protect
them from going on a journey that might
well cost them their lives and so the
idea is simply that you can't have a
great pirate adventure with loving
mothers around now this statement may
sound very trivial but when you stop and
think about what we just discussed about
the straw hats oda took great care to
include the negative implications of not
having a mom into consideration all the
most tragic backstories in the story are
related to either losing a mom or being
abandoned by one
[Music]
and as a result bringing out either the
best or the worst in people for example
doffy and corazon and you can really see
it with everyone a sabo law oda knows
that mothers are important but was smart
enough to keep them out of his adventure
story which will be actually really
important later when we will look at the
possible candidates for luffy's mom and
honestly whether or not he was aware of
all the fantastic effects that this
decision would have as a 20 year old i
think this decision has contributed
immensely to why one piece works so well
as a story just think about it for a
second well at first glance it might be
really easy to go fully woke and say oh
oda doesn't like women the truth is
loving mothers are something extremely
treasured and rare in this world if you
have a loving mom you have won the
ultimate jackpot you can live a happy
life away from violence and hate and so
the fact that there literally are no
loving moms in one piece motivates the
entire story seriously all the
characters now have motivation and
reason to become pirates they all have
the potential to be saved by luffy
because he is the one that gives them
unconditional love that they're supposed
to get from their mothers as a result
crews like luffys or whitebeards are the
real loving families in one piece
because there are no regular loving ones
[Music]
it's why brotherly bonds like that of
luffy sabo and ace or that of noriko and
nami are more common than having actual
siblings and it's also the reason why
crews like doflamingos exist where
really kind characters like baby five
tried to find some twisted sense of love
and belonging
and then of course there is big mom's
crew who is a pure caricature and dark
twist on the entire concept of a loving
mother a woman so overly obsessed with
creating a big family for everyone in
the world and so scarred by being
abandoned by mother caramel that she
ironically lost sight of her actual
children just using them as tools
[Music]
just as oda says real loving moms are
the opposite of adventure and pirates
and yeah big mom isn't a real loving mom
but i think it goes even further than
that the fact that there are no mothers
in one piece and all the tragedy that
comes with it is in a way the biggest
reason why this world is broken and
needs fixing so badly a world in which
pirate crews revolutionary armies and
marines are the only family people can
have many of them emotionally scarred is
a world that needs to change
fundamentally i strongly believe that
the dawn luffy needs to bring has to
shine on a world where kids can grow up
in the arms of their mothers not having
to fight
wow
i really went a little bit deep on this
one huh but i really love how deep one
piece always turns out to be when you
dig just a little bit beneath the
surface before we get into luffy and his
mom now if you're enjoying these type of
deep dives and some good theories on top
i'd really appreciate it immensely if
you considered subscribing to this
channel for more weekly wanted content
just like this okay so
luffy's mom it's difficult to talk about
who and where she might be because luffy
does already have a stepmom of sorts if
you know what i mean
[Music]
dadan is pretty much luffy's loving
mother figure that while tough raced him
in a prim more or less caring home and
luffy does love dad and back like a son
even if he doesn't see her as a literal
mom
[Music]
in a way you could even argue that luffy
might be so incredibly special in this
world because he grew up with a loving
if violent family of bandits his two
brothers and garp so why do i think that
after all that luffy even needs a mom
and that we will definitely meet her in
the story well some of it comes from oda
the man himself in very tiny tiny bites
and bits as always it was he himself
that told us that luffy's mom is still
alive and that he has already drawn her
but on top of that we just discussed
that oda actually thinks so highly of
motherly characters and their influence
that he consciously decided to keep her
away from luffy he described that as
luffy starting his adventure the moment
he left his parents arms what i
personally think oda is hinting at with
this is that we will only meet luffy's
mother at the end of the story actually
no we will already find out sooner than
luffy but luffy himself will only meet
his mother towards the end when his
adventure is over i've talked about this
before but i like to think that luffy's
adventure ends with finding the one
piece and that the big war that must
follow after is in a way a separate or
new story so to me it would make
absolute sense if he met his mom after
reaching love tale but before the final
big war or showdown whatever it'll be i
know people for some reason really hate
the idea of the straw hats being special
or luffy being the chosen one because i
guess they feel like it would undermine
his achievements and i have bad and good
news for you because luffy is definitely
the chosen one but that doesn't take
away anything from all that he has
already
[Music]
luffy's choices and all he has worked
for matters it's just that being born
special gave him the chance to reach his
full potential in the first place but
nonetheless it was still up to luffy to
live up to that potential and the same
goes for characters like sanji ozaro who
we now know also come from unique and
special circumstances but because they
have all worked really hard and
sacrificed a lot to reach the level that
they're at right now i think it doesn't
take away at all from all their
achievements
[Music]
my point here is that luffy the grandson
of the strongest marine and the son of
the leader of the revolutionary army
definitely will have a special mother no
question about it the only question we
now have to answer and boy
it's a big one is who
who is luffy's mom so i now want to run
through all the possible candidates we
have so far and let me warn you you
might be surprised about the last
character i propose here now one of the
most popular theories out there is the
forbidden love theory
the idea here is that dragon met a
celestial dragon and after spending more
and more time together a romance began
to bloom this would be a classic bird in
the golden cage scenario where the woman
yearns for the same sort of freedom that
dragon enjoys and at some point they
have a little baby together and so as
the other celestial dragons find out she
is ultimately killed for mixing royal
blood with that of a commoner this and
all the other knowledge about the rulers
of the world he has now gathered is what
motivates dragon to form the
revolutionary army he hands off luffy to
garb and dedicates his life to taking
down the world nobles i personally think
this theory is pretty reasonable and
straightforward it's a classic forbidden
love romeo and juliet sort of approach
that would motivate dragon but also give
luffy some unique background that might
be important towards the end of the
story doesn't exactly blow me away but
it's solid enough another really
interesting candidate is bello betty one
of the commanders of the revolutionary
army
[Music]
betty is the commander of the east blue
which is exactly where luffy grew up and
her abilities to boost up people's will
and rally them to her cause is something
she shares with our hero as well on top
of that since oda mentioned that he
would draw luffy's parents in volume 45
people have been speculating that this
woman right here might be luffy's mom
and so that might just be an early
version of betty for all we know now
this theory does something that all the
other theories can't do which is
breaking dragon and his partner actually
close together and have them work
towards a common goal it also fits in
with oda telling us that she's still
alive and i would actually enjoy this
one a lot betty is no regular character
but also not someone super overly famous
and mysterious just someone fighting the
government alongside dragon pretty
decent i'd say a very short theory is
that luffy's mom was actually gold
roger's sister this idea is based on the
fact that d seem to have kids with
other d's
[Music]
that goes for ace the only person we
actually know both parents of but jaguar
di saul also mentioned that everyone in
his family was a d so if it takes 2ds to
make the one who can bring the dawn
luffy's mother would also have to be one
this could of course be true if she was
actually garp's daughter but if not
what's better family for luffy to have
blood from than the goal family i
actually do really like this idea even
if it's a bit out there because it would
bring luffy closer to both roger and ace
but it also begs the question
why no one ever mentioned roger's sister
before now however it's time for one of
my favorite candidates here and that is
jewelry bonnie
she's actually a really interesting
character no matter what unrelated to
all this here because bonnie's devil
fruit allows her to change her age and
presumably that of others we have no
idea who she really might be her biggest
character trait is her gluttony that
mirrors luffy's own appetite like no
other character plus her face does look
quite a lot like luffy's bonnie saved
zorro from attacking a celestial dragon
even though she could have easily not
cared about the marines coming and
simply disguised herself as a kid or old
woman but we also know that bonnie has
some ties to the revolutionary army and
dragon through kuma as we saw during the
reverie
kuma who somehow knew about luffy being
dragon's son even before ivankov knew
and it might be easy to think that she
just snuck into the holy land separately
from the revolutionaries but since she's
there to save kuma wouldn't it make way
more sense for her to have come with
them then there was also this weird
situation with blackbeard and the kainu
and on top of that bonnie is inspired by
the most famous female pirate in history
and bonnie who escaped her execution and
was reportedly pregnant at the time of
her escape plus we have of course the
legendary reference to bonnie and clyde
which would fit pretty damn well with
her and dragon now as promised i'm gonna
share my thoughts and new insights on
the croco mom theory with you as well
however since this video as you can see
is already long enough as it is crocoman
will get its own entire special video
that will be released three days from
now or if you're from the future it's
already here until then i strongly
recommend you check out my video on
luffy's father dragon as well
is it here or not is it might be
invisible you like maybe it's or
maybe it's already